Hey youtubers it’s Charlie and this week
The Flash introduced Robbie Amell as Ronnie
Raymond and the Kyle Nimbus character from
the comics.
He was The Mist on the show, but in the comics
he was a little different so I’ll explain
that during my Top 5 moments.
It was definitely my favorite episode so far,
so careful for spoilers if you haven’t seen
it.
Starting with Number 5 - Meet Kyle Nimbus
aka The Mist
In the comics, Kyle Nimbus was from the starman
comics and was known as the son of The Mist.
So that was a minor change.
I also think it’s cool they did a character
from outside the flash comics.
Like they pulled in other titles.
It means that we could see characters from
all over the dc universe in the future.
On the show I really appreciated the way they
presented his powers using science.
I feel like The Flash as a show has been winning
at Science.
Maybe it’s just because I love hard science
fiction so much, but magic or super powers
are just science we haven’t learned to understand
yet.
Science will always win.
Remember that idea, it’s important to understanding
what’s going on with Harrison Wells and
the great villain arc this season.
Science will always win over raw muscle.
That’s why people are always able to outsmart
Superman.
Although technically he’s a pretty good
scientist to.
The movies and the tv shows have just done
a very poor job of portraying that.
Number 4 - The Particle Accelerator Becomes
a Metahuman Prison
Crazy thought here, Harrison Wells talked
about finding a way to take away their powers.
Imagine by the end of the season they capture
a bunch of metahumans.
What if Harrison wants to use their powers
to fuel some big catastrophe.
Or even just steal the energy to make himself
more powerfull.
If he really is Eobard Thawne from the comics,
he already has the Negative Speed Force.
Regardless of what their long term plan is
for all the future inmates, it looks badass
from a visual perspective.
It’s like Cerebro on Steroids.
It’s a super collider like the one at CERN.
So that’s why it looks like the Large Hadron
Collider.
Their design was inspired by the large hadron
collider.
If you look at it in real life it’s like
a masterpiece of science and engineering artwork.
I think they said that the Star Labs collider
is non functioning.
But the parts that still do work are what
they’re using to power the prison cells.
But as a facility it’s massive.
It’s like the size of the Triskelion in
the Marvel Universe.
And it’s all underground.
Number 3 - Grant Gustin and John Wesley Shipp
Just in general all the Original Flash scenes
were great.
When I’m watching the show I just call the
scenes he gets with Grant Gustin Flash Squared
moments.
His dad’s character is the moral lightning
rod of the show.
Just to make a flash joke.
So he gets to be the wise master teaching
Grant Gustin what it means to be a hero without
it turning into a classroom learning situation.
He’s Barry’s Jonathan Kent.
Jonathan is the moral core of superman so
when you think of John Wesley Shipp just think
of him like that.
He shares the job a little with Detective
West, a lot of what he said was pretty obvious
foreshadowing like “you can’t save everyone”
so when you look at his dad’s line “you
ran to your mother”.
You can imagine what they’re teasing.
Barry has to learn that even if he can run
fast enough to save everyone, he still can’t
save everyone.
Now twist that on it’s head with Harrison
Well’s line “You’d be surprised what
you can live with”.
Using Barry as context, he’ll learn to live
with his mother’s death eventually.
Even with all of his powers.
Number 2 - Harrison Wells Flashback
After the flashback that line “you’d be
surprised at what you can live with” is
so much more important.
He clearly precipitated the particle accelerator
explosion to cause the tear in spacetime facilitating
Barry’s speed force accident.
There is a predestination paradox at play
that comic book readers will know all about.
So if you have read Flash Rebirth, just please
use spoiler tags.
But think of what Oliver Queen told Barry
in episode 1 “I think that Lightning Chose
You”.
That means more than you think it means.
They’ll explain that by the end of season
1.
It doesn’t mean that Harrison Wells is the
lightning, he didn’t directly give Barry
his powers.
He just knew what needed to happen in order
for him to get the powers.
So he helped facilitate it with the explosion.
It makes you wonder how long had Wells been
working at Star Labs?
I wouldn’t be surprised if it turned out
he mysteriously started working there right
after Barry’s Mother was Murdered.
Number 1 - Meet Ronnie Raymond aka Firestorm